こちらしていくか不安ですしばらくの間日本語のビデオをやってないんです
まあそういえばですねしばらくの間は日本語も話してないんですよ
私がこちらバンクーバーに住んでます
そして
まあ言葉の勉強に対して非常に興味がありますので
しかし最近はねロシア語に中心にですねロシア語を中心に
まあ
それだけでもだいぶまあ忙しくなったわけでしょ言葉の勉強に関してはですよ
そして最近はまあたちは皇后を始めたんですよ5ヶ月前に
だから日本語はまぁ時々ですね
木材の仕事の関係で時々その日本人とあってですね
知能お客さんとあって日本語を話しするんだけども
もうメタですよ
一月に一度か2月に1度ぐらいんですよ
まあそういうことも含めて少し日本語の練習ということで少し
日本語のビデオをやろうと
決めたわけですよな人について話ししようかというとですね
言葉の勉強というにはねぇ楽しいなんですよ
楽しい極めて楽しいことなんですよ
楽しいだからその勉強方法自体もやり方によってですねー
べきの過程も楽しいしそれからあの新しい言葉を勉強できたらですね
そこでですねその国の歴史文化あるいはその国の人間といろんな関係が出来るからです
ね
まあ大変
楽しい
a
何ですか趣味だと思います
と思いますだけどもだけどもね
日本語ではそうじゃないんですよね日本語ではもう言葉の勉強というのはこれは義務で
言葉の勉強というよりも日本でも英語ですよ
もう英語と日本語しかもう存在しないような
ぬふり
いいですよ日本はね
ねあの a しかし実際はもう観光これは中国棒からもうスペイン語からもうなぁ
いろいろあるんですよ雑魚とかね
だけど日本ではですねもうとにかく日本で私は日本
この前ですねこれが1年前ですね大体においた時にですね
必ず日本の本屋さん行ってます尋ねますどういう新しいものでましたかと
まあ見に行きますよねそしてまあええ言葉のセクションも尋ねてみます
ズルもちろん英語勉強のほうが圧倒的に多いですよねまぁ若干韓国語やフランス語や
中国語があるけれどももうほとんど8割9割はまあ営業の勉強
それで毛根がたくさんたくさんあるその半分以上はな
また toefl とか toeic の勉強
4それだけでテストの免許それが半分以上
あるいはその
毒粟の穂カビる単語単語表
消し単語だけをその勉強するのはですね言葉の勉強にならないんですよね
言葉というのは面白く
面白い
ストーリーも白い内容
面白いものいギター言葉から勉強するのが一番効果的ですよ
と行くの
5年間のテスト勉強しようとか
何がそのどこそこの単語をですね一生懸命勉強しようっていうのはね
それ非常に高価低いんですそれがそういうようなことをやってもですなんですね
それが短期的メモリーにしか入らないんですよ
長期的にそれを本当に自分のものにすることはできないんですよ
だから
例えば私が11ヶ国語話せるんですよ
今もーちゃこ
もう5ヶ月間前に始めたんだけど今新聞も嫁は志布志港これ
他の人やってるから
でそういうは滝の方法でですね
楽しくやるとですねこれ長期的にメモリに入るんですよ
それがその能力はなくならないんですよだけど例えば私が中国語を勉強してそれから
日本に9年住んでたんだけども
中国語を忘れなかったんです
あるいはもうほとんどには日本語を話ししませんけれども
まあ今話ししようと思ってもの若干
覚えない単語とかあるけれどもまだいた意味がある通じますかね
だから言葉というのは楽しく
堪能祝やらないといけないだから日本のように
たくさんの人がいい
まず英語に興味ないなんでいで英語勉強しなくちゃ
日本ではそんな英語はいらないんじゃないかとまぁそれはそうなんですよ
だからまずだったなあなたが何に対して興味あるのか
英語に興味なければせんでいいよあなたはまあスペイン語や中国語
あるいはどう何か興味感じないと
ベーカーできないで興味がなくてもですよ
なくてもやり出すと面白い
やり方でやればその a
食欲が出てくるんですよそれもやはり
まあ文法だけを勉強するとか単秒
タンゴー表だけをするとかと行くのテストだけをもう集中的に勉強するとかそれの宿版
の何を橇参加したですね
そういうようなことはですねその色4個割ってないんです
仮にその感覚すっうそ
園庭が冠馬ですね趣味
あるいは
何ですかん
好奇心とか
これ可能その他の所になり
可能性じゃ考えてもですねそれはすすぐダウンあるんですよ
それはなぜかというとそういうような勉強方法は面白くない
他の少ない効果的もないだから
いかにしてねその勉強を楽しくするかというのはそれは先生に披露
生徒の後ろそれが第一の目標4どうすればそれが楽しくなるかとまあそれは
じゃあ歌を聴きたいとかテレビ番組を
なみたいとかだけどもテレビ番組見てもですねわからないと面白くない
だから彼らずその聞く者に対してはやはり文章を探して
そして文章も読みながらまた見たり聞いたり読んだり
そしてやはり少しずつ合意を増やしていけば
そしてその過程においてですね文法がだんだん
わかりやすくなってくる
ロシア語でもじゃあ久保でも文法が非常に複雑なんですよ英語よりもはるかに複雑だ
けれどもその最初の時に私があまりたくさん
ちぇ皇后とかロシア語は頭に入ってない段階でねあのいろんな文法的説明を聞いても
ですねわからないし
防衛が
れないんですよだけども今
着でもね5ヶ月間でですねこの間私のリンクであの東京みましたけれども
うちのリンクシステムでね読むこの単語の数を数えるわけですよねなんと20万単語も
6すでにも選んだ理由ですよ
それがかなり
のだからその客子という言葉ですね
選んでそれですべてのその文章も効くんですよ
ていきます
だからずもの中にはですねそれだけたくさんチェックオーバー入ってるわけ
それだけ経験がある
ねだからそういう
だいたい経験のある者に対しての説明だで文法説明がその時に
こういう文法にぶつかるとですね若干を張るんですよ
そしてあの覚える可能性があるだけでも住まず楽しく
私は立場歴史に今日やるから歴史の本読んだり
それを受けのリンクシステム助けになっていくけれどもやはりそれを読んでますそれ
なりの
たん5号8まベインまあ覚えてるわけ
だから轍だとよされ楽しいたほかの人は歴史に興味がなければまあこれは音楽だとか他
のものにでも
まあマン眠いけれども興味のあるようなものに集中すれば
a 楽しくうそれをわからなくても構わない
それは大事ですね言葉の勉強を楽しくするにはですね
もう一つの要素はね
は所へましたこと
弾いません必ずはする忘れる
勉強しただ自称開いてみて調べて辞書
閉じて忘れました誰でもそうなんですよ
だからは滑る覚えるものは忘れるわからない必ず分からない
仗助ね町長にですねこれが分かる分かるようには少しずつなる
で歩いわかる次にわからないある日は話できて
次には話でいきたいか回らないんです構いません
全然構いませんそういうでそういう
ミステイクがあっても構いませんそういうとにかく
も言葉にぶつかってにてできるだけその命と耳を通じてたくさん入ってもらおうと
そして施工費ずつその中から
イヤー単語やフレーズやその時になったら興味がありました
文法とそしてミスがあっても構いません
そういうような楽しくそれでたくさん
これ単独何ですか単調単独たん所じゃなくて超得
調教
とにかくたくさん器具たくさん読む
楽しくそういうことを中心に勉強すればあとは東映は問題じゃないんですよ
そういうえ
もう言葉にそういう馴染みがあれば英語とそういう馴染みがあれば合意も豊富にあれば
それもちろん単語とフレーズ
豊富にあれば遠い子は問題じゃないです
東いくはちょっとちょっとした本を買えば核はこんな
こんなその質問があったということだだけでも遠い区専門のコースなって全然ダメなん
ですよ
それが遠いも良くならないしそして言葉空のものも良くならないそれでやはり
何の為に勉強するかそれがコミュニケーション
それはへ
興味のある
言葉のを使ってですね本や映画いい
テレビ番組ヴィヴィオ音楽その国の人と楽しくそれあの付き合ってですね
自分の園生活自分の寿命それだけに豊富すると
だからすべて楽しく楽しくやらないと
あんまりいいいい気変わってないとだからどうやってね
その言葉の勉強を楽し奇数楽しくうするというのはそれはまあ先生がいれば先生もそれ
をメイン無目的にすべきなんですよ
文法の説明はどうでもいい
制度あの勉強する人それがどうせ
勉強する人が鍵なんですよ本人が本人の態度本人のそのコミック面とですか本人の
そして勉強自分が自分の道を選べないといけませんまあそれがそういう
ようなことできればこと等勉強は楽しくなる非常にまた
あるですよ効果がよく何まあそういうようなことです
なんかあの意見もあればどうぞどんどん言ってください
玉